- You used to carry something
in your wallet I hear.
What did you carry in your wallet?
- Just a casual laminated
photo of Leo DiCaprio.
(Kelly laughs)
I don't think it's...
- [Kelly] What, a casual?
- [Eliza] No like it was...
- You have casual and laminated,
those don't exist together.
- Laminating things was like very big,
back when I was in middle school.
And in the library at my high school,
I was in high school, I guess.
So this goes, I wasn't
as young as I should be
to be doing this, it was just last year.
Just last year. Let me get it.
No, I laminated this photo of him
'cause I loved this photo of him.
And I was like, it was from
like Teen Bop Magazine.
And I was like, no, this
is gonna get ripped.
This is, this is,
it was so-
- It was like The Bible.
- I'm saying this out loud. I know.
I'm saying this out loud
and I'm a little concerned for myself.
(Kelly laughs)
- I think plenty of
girls had Leo laminated.
- Yeah. But like, we were
in a legit relationship.
(Kelly laughs)
- He didn't know.
- He had no idea.
- Yeah.
- No, it was fine.
It was a great moment though.
- Yeah.
- I love that you carried it around.
We all have our weird things.